all right i saw this last night and i i
don't know where this is going to go as
it relates to the nfl i'm intrigued by
it as it relates to the nba multiple nba
teams have done away with the term owner
within the past year that's a report
from tmz other teams have discussed
making a similar change draymond green
the warriors forward said on hbo's the
shop last year you shouldn't say owner
the idea there is that there is a
certain degree of racial insensitivity
to it and when you just rattle off owner
owner owner it it harkens back to the
days when human beings owned other human
beings as slaves so i get the
sensitivity the challenge is especially
to relate to the nfl i don't know what
other term you use and i'm not being
obtuse here i'm not being stupid i don't
know what other term you use and that's
kind of what we're looking at now
because you can't just say ceo because
on some teams there's a ceo who isn't
the owner right so it's almost like you
have to know the specific title that is
given to each owner and use that title
but the problem is for a lot of these
teams the title is owner so until they
change the title i don't know what to do
and and as i say that i'm i'm very aware
that
you know i don't use the name of the
washington franchise because people say
to me well that's the name you should
use it well i don't because i can still
refer to them by saying washington i
don't know how i can refer to and
identify what the role is of robert
craft what the role is of of uh you know
any other person who owns
equity
in an nfl team so i i you know here's
the thing here's what's gonna happen
they're gonna be a lot of people who
think it's the right thing to do there's
gonna be a lot of people who think it's
horribly a bad decision and it's the
death of society and it's political
correctness run amok and it's all these
negative you know it's it's it's
it's gonna become a flash point for a
lot of people of course because we can't
agree on anything and people are going
to be pissed off about this one no i
mean you're i mean the first thing i
thought of is so what do we call them
the purchaser hey mr hey the the
purchasers here for practice today i i'm
the same way i understand i don't like
that either i know i don't doesn't work
either did we come up with a nickname
did we just call him big money hey big
money's here or daddy warbucks is here i
mean you know i don't know you're you're
right you know here comes this guy who
signs the chest mr tall stacks is here
he's always got stacks of cash check
signer how about check signing jackson
check signer sure sure i i'm gonna go
until i come up with something better
i'm going with check signer it's a i
mean uh i i i understand the sensitivity
i i i can understand both sides of that
argument there the sensitivity then also
people going okay that's a little
overblown that way uh but i guess it's
different you know you're owning a team
and there's 12 players on that team so i
get that too i understand it but it is
going to be funny to figure or see what
what name they come out with instead of
owner
but if there's an easy fix why not do it
yeah if that's the thing that drives me
crazy
the whole the railing against political
correctness well
correctness
right there's there's some there's a
reason to avoid saying certain things
that may offend someone else that may be
viewed as insensitive shouldn't we
aspire to do that if all things are
equal that's the thing as long as we can
come up with an acceptable alternative
then then what's the big deal but why do
oh political correctness run amok who
cares how does it affect you you still
get to communicate your thoughts you're
just using words that clearly are not
potentially viewed as insensitive by
anyone yeah why i mean you know it's
it's the the the you know the the the
rule that gets you through life
platinum rule golden rule just don't be
an [ __ ] that's right be nice if you
need to right but just don't be an
[ __ ] yeah and and and if you now
sometimes you inadvertently are an
[ __ ] because you don't realize but
once you realize once you see how
something may affect someone then you
you stop saying it you stop doing that
now ideally you figure that stuff out
without you know having to be told
you're being an [ __ ] but i just think
that's the safest course don't be an
[ __ ] that's that's the best way to
live your life if maybe if i ever write
a book the title will be don't be an
[ __ ] written by an [ __ ] yeah
and who better to write a book about an
[ __ ] than the [ __ ] so yeah you'd
be the one to write it that's for sure
i'll give you that much uh but yes i
like what you said
well said well said though that i mean
it's what i try to tell my kids all the
time uh it's about being nice it's about
how you treat people you know you can
get a bad grade and daddy might not be
happy but i'm not gonna yell at you if i
hear you're mistreating people you know
saying things that are inappropriate
then you're in then my kids know they're
in deep crap with daddy and there might
be some consequences that that come
along with that
well uh i look i don't know where this
one's gonna go i'm gonna continue to
monitor it and and i i don't know i i'm
gonna look i've got the record in fact
book and i'm gonna look and see what
these owners are called by their teams
and and maybe it has to come from them
maybe they need to come up with other
names and then those are the names that
we will use but check signer for me is
the only
the only halfway decent alternative i
can think up right now but it's
something we're going to continue to
look at because look if if there is a
question if there's a fair question that
it's viewed as racially insensitive then
why should you want to use that term
it's something that we should think
about we should talk about and if there
is an easy alternative why not use it if
there's any chance it's potentially
insensitive at all find a different word
that's not hard to do it's a lot easier
than complaining about it incessantly
like so many people are going to want to
do yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports